let's talk about watchdog's legion
online that's right watchdogs is getting
an
online component and i'm joined by phil
hornshaw to talk about if that improves
the game
who this might be for and what sort of
activities you can do
in the online environment oh yes as
always if you guys want to hear more
about watch dogs give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel
alright let's get into it phil who is
watchdogs online
primarily for if you really dig
watchdog's legion
already this is kind of a new cool way
to get into that game with other people
it sort of
feels like it's either very casual like
you're just messing around in the
online world or you're really into it
and you really want to get in there with
like a team
of hackers who are going to be going
after some really high level
activities so like either you want to
just mess around and
you know crash cars into rivers like we
were doing
or uh you want to do multi-step
um lengthier quests where you actually
have to you know coordinate and do
tactics and stuff like that so
uh either one of those two things but
kind of only those two things this was
kind of how i felt about it
those are legitimately two pretty
different extremes and i think that's
something that we ran into in this
preview event
uh periodically so let's kind of break
down a couple of these
individually let's start with just the
free roam environment what can you do in
free roam co-op so free room is mostly
it seems like about either playing by
yourself when you're online
you can do solo missions and just pick
up missions like you would in watchdogs
legion when you're playing
offline but it's also about you know
finding more characters that you can
recruit to your
deadset team just like you do in the
single player component of the game
and you know you're that's the crux of
the game you're building out this team
that you can just
call on at any moment so you're off
there
doing that sort of thing out in london
just like enjoying yourself
stealing cars messing with people
grabbing stuff
there are collectibles to find and um
sort of daily and weekly challenges that
you can do free roam stuff is
primarily just giving you something to
do while you're waiting basically for
other people to come
join up on your team and do some of the
more high-level events
something that we ran into in that mode
was there were also public events that
were a little bit similar to how destiny
handles them
although we didn't we didn't see a ton
of those i would like to point out that
we tested the solo missions to see if
you could bring somebody with you
and it seemed like somebody could come
with you on the solo mission but it
didn't count towards your progress
there's a whole separate co-op section
for that yeah it was actually a little
weird like
you can be on a team and they can be in
the same open world instance as you but
if you start up a solo mission it is a
solo mission
like they don't get any pings on their
map they don't get any waypoints or
anything like that
you just gotta uh kind of follow along
if you want to help somebody out on a
solo mission but then again they're not
all that involved either it's not like
you need teammates or anything like that
one important thing to circle back on
that you mentioned was recruiting people
in
online it's different than it is in the
main game
you actually spend i believe it's tech
points on it
and in our playthrough we didn't earn
any tech points in the world we earned
those through
their equivalent of a season pass i
believe it was like
one through 50 rank um and you
occasionally rank up that pass
and you you get through it by playing
the game but also just doing like silly
stuff
you know you mentioned you crashed cars
into a river for a challenge that whole
system
is based on i think they're called
influence points in this case in the
online case
and yeah you earn them basically by
completing objectives to earn experience
points and that's what kicks up your
season rank and like you said you have
that whole
that whole seasonal season pass sort of
thing i don't i don't think it is a
season pass in the same way you would
think of
one as in destiny or fortnite where you
pay into it necessarily
um there's only one track and it's all
experience based but it is like a
ranking system that keeps you busy and
like keeps you chasing different
rewards over time and then yeah you have
your daily challenges one of them
we keep talking about this but i had to
like cap uh steal double decker buses
and crash them into rivers and like
do three of those and you get a spike of
influence points that sort of thing and
then there were weekly challenges too
they're sort of fun and goofy they seem
like they're you know a mix of
the kind of online shooter play that you
would expect and also goofy online
open world things and yeah once you get
those influence points you spend them on
either characters
that you can find in the world and
depending on how you know
good or useful those characters are they
cost more points
and then you also use them to um unlock
different tech abilities for those
characters
like you do in the single player
campaign where so you can
hack different drones or send
you know get spider bots or whatever
other
tactical gear you want to get all those
things are unlocked in a different skill
tree thing
and they all cost influence points too
so you're earning influence points for
everything you do
kind of because it's a global system but
also they're not
specific to any one thing you're not
like okay i have to go play this today
so that i can get an influence point to
do whatever i want to do it's always
just everything you do gets influence
points eventually
so the other thing to talk about we've
talked about the very casual elements in
free room
the flip side that i want to dive into a
little bit is co-op and then we'll talk
about their
sort of like raid light or i think you
mentioned strike-ish mechanics from
similar to destiny there are co-op
missions in this world which is what i
think a lot of people want to you know
come here to play
the co-op missions were definitely
interesting i i
they oscillate between like you just
messing around
in almost a combined arms environment
with your friends so combining your
powers
to take down enemies somebody stuns
somebody shoots somebody grabs a car and
runs people over
that was fun but there's also there's
also a lot of mechanics in this game
that require two people to do something
simultaneously
and we didn't see a lot of off mic
communication tools to do that it could
be tough for random people versus people
who
come into this with their friends albion
has put an electronic nerve agent
released in his restraints
if you try to take it off or move in
before it's disabled the nerve agent is
released and
boof dead vigilante it resets quickly
too
so if you want to frame you have to hack
the detonator control at the same time
you undo the restraints
this is definitely feels like the kind
of game that you want to have people you
know
playing with you on uh and yeah you're
gonna have to be on mic one had us like
saving a vigilante who had been captured
by the evil
pmc group in london and so to get to him
first we had to infiltrate
a construction site and then we had to
hack one computer
and un handcuff him at the same time
because
if you undid his handcuffs without
hacking the computer he would explode
so uh we had to you know coordinate on
that there was a little timer that kind
of gave us
an idea of you know okay you took the
handcuffs off too early you've got 15
seconds to deal with the hacking
primarily like we had to
know what we were doing and plan for it
and get people in the right places at
the right times so yeah this is the kind
of game
it feels like if you want to mess around
in the open world that's one thing but
if you really want to get into these
missions
they're pretty involved and you're going
to need people you know who know what
they're doing
that you can trust to play with yeah and
that kind of came back to
some things that i get concerned about
in some ubi games which is
you know you saw this in the division
two the confusion of
hard with cheap and some of these
mechanics felt
cheap rather than hard if you didn't do
them at the exact same time with
potentially random people you didn't
just get kicked back one you got
back maybe like two checkpoints and you
had to do everything all over again
so there's some potential frustration
there if there aren't tools in this game
that either we didn't see or they
haven't put in there yet just to allow
random players to
do these sort of coordinated activities
together so that's the light side of
things
let's talk about tactical ops because we
we got into tactical ops on a mission
that we spent most of our preview on
it had raid like mechanics and i think
somebody in our group hadn't raided
before
so what was that like with with random
people
yeah it was those are tough those
tactical ops
missions are really going to test your
watchdogs abilities they're the kind of
things that were like you need to recon
the area you need to check out
the the um local security cameras to
kind of get the lay of the land
you need to bring all your best skills
and get your best characters in for this
and yeah we had a tough time i would um
i would liken it it's not quite a raid
i don't think because i think people do
have a sort of an idea of what
to expect when you say the word raid i
would liken them maybe to destiny's
dungeons
they are mechanic heavy and they are
multi-step and they are tough
so the one we played um first we had to
deal with these like giant military
drones that had gone
um haywire who were in invulnerable by
the way
oh yeah oh yeah that's right you
couldn't destroy like most of the time
you can at least shoot the robots down
or stun them or whatever
these things are patrolling sections of
london like just rolling through the
streets
looking for people to kill and you can't
do anything about them we had to do an
elaborate
hacking thing in order to um bring them
down we eventually figured out that we
were not
good enough at stealth but we were a we
were able to do that
ride the drone thing that makes legion
so cool so we were able to like call on
a construction drone we all climbed on
top of it we all flew over top of these
guys
to avoid being seen but uh then we
figured out that once we had hacked them
and we could make them
vulnerable we had to get back down on
the ground and actually fight and it was
it was pretty involved and it was very
tough and the other thing about
technical ops and co-op in general is
that your teammates can be knocked down
um like in a lot of live games and once
they're down they have a bleed out timer
and if they
if that timer runs out everybody gets
kicked back like you don't
get to respawn to make it well in the in
the easier co-op missions
people respawn and you know delivers out
of the game for a bit but in the
tactical ops you like
your team has to survive everybody has
to be on point
you have to make sure you're close
enough together so that you can do those
revives
and uh it cascaded badly for us a few
times when
somebody would go down sometimes dying
up on a drone
and then like way up out of out of sight
and stuff like that
so yeah this is the kind of activity
that is high enough level that you're
going to want to get
your like strong team in people who uh
who are going to communicate and
coordinate really tightly
because they were tough one other really
important thing to point out is
that when your characters die in these
instances they don't get arrested or
anything like that
that's not to say that i didn't have a
character get arrested
in the open world right before we went
into one of these events and lost
the best character before we tried it
which yeah
well we should say that tactical ops are
these are
end game activities like this isn't
stuff you kind of stumble into tactical
apps are
a thing that you're gonna plan for and
that you are
hitting when you are hitting the top of
watchdogs legion that's when you're
going after these so they are really
hard
phil another open world side activity
was spiderbot arena
i think you had a really good time
mostly because you murdered everybody i
kind of felt like i'd had it after a
round or two
maybe a good palette cleanser what are
your thoughts on that mode
yeah i this is one of those more casual
things i think that gives you more
options if you don't really want to jump
in with a big team or go do some lengthy
co-op quest
um they're fun i thought they were fun
it's usual it's like standard deathmatch
you
run around as a spiderbot and pick up
weapons
and then blast away at each other and
the more kills you get
like you kind of build up a kill streak
in a sort of call of duty style so
you know you you're harder to kill and
you
i think get better guns i forget exactly
how it worked
um but yeah there it's a good time and
it's also short
bursts of four four on four or four
player action i think it was
um they're not i don't think they're
team based they're mostly free for all
uh or at least the rounds that we played
were and yeah they're
just quick death match maps i don't
think that they're supposed to be like
the main attraction
but they are kind of nice to jump into
for a second you know
in between bigger missions or while
you're waiting for friends they give you
something to do
um when you're not out in the world
which is kind of nice
i don't know i liked it i thought it was
fun i did go on a kill streak in one of
those rounds so that was
that was part of why i had a good time i
think
all right so that was our playthrough of
watch dogs legion online if it's a game
that you are still enjoying or you
haven't actually tried yet
the online mode seems like it does add
to the game but just keep in mind that
there are some very casual elements to
it but there are also some
pretty hardcore elements that you'll
need a team to do if you guys want to
hear more about ubi games more about
watch dogs
ubi's making apparently a star wars game
now
make sure to give us a like and
subscribe to our channel and we will
tell you all about it as we learn
alright thanks for watching guys
[Music]
you